So chat, schon jemand da?
Oh, ich hab den Chat gar nicht auf, null, kein Wunder, das seh ich ja gar nicht, was
Sache ist.
So, jetzt aber, sollen wir mal vor allem starten.
Chat, heut war richtig was los in Frankfurt, sag ich euch, heut war die Kacke am dampfen,
sozusagen.
Heute ist in Frankfurt eine S-Bahn entgleist und, hallo, was los?
Genau, ja, also, was ich sagen wollte, heute ist in Frankfurt richtig was los, los gewesen,
und zwar heute ist nicht nur eine S-Bahn entgleist.
Oh, ich seh keine Subscribers mehr im Chat, toll, Tainser, 18 Monate, Dankeschön, Massive
Subscription.
Eher zu dem Auscover gleich, heute ist nicht nur eine S-Bahn, was ich sagen wollte, also,
heute ist in Frankfurt, war richtig was los, es ist heute in Frankfurt nicht nur eine S-Bahn
entgleist, ja, und die Leute mussten ne Stunde rumgammeln, bis sie, bis sie, ähm, bis sie
raus konnten, nein, noch mehr, noch mehr, heute hat in Frankfurt noch einer in der S-Bahn
Leute mit dem Revolver bedroht.
Alter, heute ging es so, heute war was los in Frankfurt, und ja Leute, falls ihr es noch
nicht gemerkt habt, wir haben neue Emotes, guckt mal, guckt mal, wir haben neue Emotes,
Cutie-Modes, wer weiß nicht wie Cuties sind, aber die sind ganz passend.
Ich mein, auf 100% erkennt man nicht, auf 100% ist halt so die Sache, aber ganz ehrlich,
hat irgendjemand seinen Twitch-Chat auf 100%?
Also ich mein, ich hab den normalerweise auf 150, pass auf, jetzt kommen die ersten Leute
und sagen, nein Max, ich hab's auf 25, 15, ja, klar, klar, ja, wie gesagt, guckt's euch
mal an, heute war wirklich in Frankfurt, war echt die Kacke am dampfen, und was riecht
ich heftig, wenn S-Bahn war, man mit Revolver bedroht Fahrgäste in der S2, ich bin früher
öfters mal S2 gefahren, ja, und das stimmt, das muss man ja auch mal sagen, es ist nicht
etwa so, als hätte ich die Emotes gemacht, also ich mein, davon ist wahrscheinlich, da
hat eh keiner gedacht, dass ich irgendwie die Emotes gemacht hätte, oder auch nur, dass
ich mich darum gekümmert hätte, weil ihr kennt mich, wenn ich sowas mache, dann passiert
da in 5 Jahren nix, ne, das haben wir alles, wo ist er, alles dem Patrik zu verdanken, exquisite
Mod, also wir haben jetzt einmal, wir haben den Cute Mod und wir haben den Vorbild Mod,
besser Mod, ja, ex, excellent, exquisite Mod, sind sie nicht nice, so, das ist jetzt nicht,
das ist nochmal so, das muss nicht so final so bleiben, ich mein, ich hab 28, ich hab nachgeguckt,
28 Emote Slots, überlegt euch das mal, 28 Emote Slots, und davon hab ich, glaub jetzt
7 verwendet, oder 8, der Mod Boss, ne, das heißt bestimmt anders, der Bubba, der Mod
Bubba ist, Mensch, MaxiKinn23, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den Sub, Massive Sub, oder
Scam Train ist schon wieder am Start, Leute, was ist denn jetzt los, sag mal, Twitch wird
auch immer frecher, was das angeht, oder, jetzt haben wir ein gutes Emote dafür, Wupp
Prime, Leute, Wupp Prime, Twitch wird auch immer frecher, oder, einer gesubbt, Instant
Scam Train am Start, SIFND, Dankeschön, ah, stimmt, es heißt ja nicht mal Twitch Prime,
es heißt ja Prime Gaming, ah, yes, Twitch, alles klar, ja, ja, so einfach ist es auch
nicht, so einfach geht das nicht, muss schon Subben, guck mal, es fehlen noch 6% bis Level
2, hättest du jetzt gesubbt, kannst du die Emotes verwenden, und es wäre auf 100%, ja,
und wenn wir die Emotes dann endlich mal aufgefüllt haben, aber machen wir noch Tier 1 und Tier
2, äh, Tier 2 und Tier 3 Maps, Maps, Alter, Maps, wie komm ich jetzt auf Maps, bitte
schön, Emotes, null, Alter, ja Level 5 ist riesen, G-Bate, stimmt, stimmt, mit Channel
Points kann man die sich für den Tag auch so freischalten, stimmt, hab ich ganz vergessen,
ja, richtig, korrekt Leute, exquisite Big Brain Chat wieder, ja guckt euch das mal an,
wie gesagt, heute S-Bahn entgleist und irgendein Dude mit dem Revolver im Zug, und jetzt kommt
der Hit, jetzt kommt der Hit, ich hab das vorher nicht gelesen, jetzt kommt der Hit, ähm,
der Typ stellst in der S-Bahn mit dem Revolver rum, und die Bahn lässt einfach die Tür
zu, nice Sub, wer hat's, ich hab's gar nicht gesehen, Warnigst, Stufe 1, Dankeschön für
den Sub, excellent Subscription, die Bahn lässt einfach die Tür zu, und ich hab mir
überlegt, okay, ist das Fail von der Bahn oder ist das Absicht, ich glaube, ich glaube,
es ist tatsächlich Absicht, also natürlich ist es doof, dass die sich da nicht dazu
geäußert haben, aber ich glaube, die wollten nicht, dass ein Typ mit der Pistole random
in der S-Bahn Station rumballert, oh, excellent Musik, also, aber ohne Scheiß, Leute, überlegt
euch mal, ihr sitzt in einem S-Bahn Wagen drin, und da rennt ein Typ mit der Pistole
rum, und ihr wollt raus, und es geht nicht, ich mein, ja, es geht, ihr könnt natürlich
die Scheibe einschlagen, mit einem dieser komischen Hemmer da, oder ihr könnt die Tür
entriegeln, aber ganz im Ernst, jeder versucht sich in so einem Moment, wenn er nicht hier
grad Chuck Norris ist oder so, versucht er sich möglichst unauffällig zu verhalten,
und als Einziger aufzustehen, zur Tür zu gehen, und die Notentriegelung aufzumachen
und die Tür aufzuziehen, ist vielleicht ein bisschen auffällig, Alter, was geht jetzt
mit der Musik ab, von wem sind die neuen Emotes gemacht, vom gleichen, der auch das AI-AI-AI-AI-E-E-Mode
gemacht hat im Chat, also nicht das, unser Bot-E-Mode, nein, es ist keine, was passiert,
allerdings in Frankfurt ist es halt so, also ich würd', also ohne Scheiß, Leute, wenn
ihr kriminelle Energie habt und Leute in der Bahn überfallen wollt, ich würd's mir
dreimal überlegen, ob ich das in Frankfurt mach, weil du hast in Frankfurt so viel fertige
Leute, die juckt das nicht, die freuen sich wahrscheinlich noch, wenn du sie erschießt,
ja, und das ist wahrscheinlich für alle Seiten gefährlich, in Frankfurt kommt einer von
hinten mit dem Messer und springt auf dich drauf, also da weißt du nie was, da weißt
du nie was, noch schlimmer, wenn du in Offenbach stehst, dann ist eh vorbei, ja, ne, aber
hier, das ist, also es kommt, in Frankfurt kommen öfters mal so Dinger vor, wir hatten
hier auch nen Typ mit der, mit ner Axt, glaub ich, hatten wir auch mal, vor einem halben
Jahr oder so, da ist mit der Axt durch den Zug, haben sie nicht sogar erschossen, den
Typ, Frankfurt-Axt-Zug, haben sie den Typ nicht sogar erschossen, ach, keine Ahnung,
ist auch egal, war das in Würzburg, aber dann war es ein Zug aus Frankfurt, oder, weil
ich hab irgendwie so im Hintergrund, das war was bei mir, aber im Ernst, also, ähm, also
wenn jemand, wenn jemand wirklich allen Ernstes mit der Axt in den Zug geht und da mit dem,
durch den Zug rennt und, und droht Leute anzuhacken, also, wenn der diese ganze Sache nicht überlebt,
da ist er wirklich selbst dran schuld, also, also irgendwie, irgendwann ist ja auch mal
gut, ja, also, also ich find, da muss man nicht, da muss man echt nicht alles hinterfragen,
immer so nach dem Motto, ha, hätte die Polizei nicht vielleicht auf den kleinen C zielen
können oder sowas in der Richtung, alter, also wenn mit dem Messer oder ner Axt durch
den Zug rennt und Leute anzuhacken will, gut, der hat halt Pech, mal ganz ehrlich, der hat
halt echt gelitten, ja, ich könnt, ich mein, es zwingt den ja keiner dazu, der könnt's
doch einfach sein lassen, da würde ihm nix passieren, der ist echt, der Scam Train ist
grad wieder volle Punne am Start, aber gleich ist er abgelaufen, Leute, gleich ist er abgelaufen,
habt ihr gesehen, Twitch, Twitch, she baited Massive, das war eben noch auf 67, äh, oder
auf 47 und es ist jetzt einfach auf 50% hochgegangen, ohne, ohne, dass da irgendwas ist, ja, einfach
Massive, Massive, nein, falsches, ja, wahrscheinlich, aber hat er Pech, ja, äh, ich bin auch psychisch
gestört und renn ich durch, mit der Axt durch den Zug, äh, steu, genau, spread, zu viel
spread, steady aim, wär jetzt kein Problem gewesen, sag ich, sag ich das nächste Mal
dem Polizist auch, hätt mal ne P90 und steady aim nehmen sollen, Leute, ich weiß nicht,
was mit YouTube vor ist, äh, was mit YouTube los ist, wisst ihr, was die mir, was das mir
vorher vorgeschlagen hat, allen Ernstes auf der Startseite, das ist kein Witz jetzt, dabei
guck ich sowas gar nicht, irgend so ein komisches Promotion Video von Carl S. wird mir vorhin
auf der Startseite vorgeschlagen, irgendein 1,5 Stunden Video, äh, keine Ahnung, irgendwas,
wo man, irgendwie was, wie man richtig Business macht wahrscheinlich oder so, also auch immer
mit YouTube los ist, ich weiß gar nicht warum, der Carl hat überhaupt keinen Aufruf mehr,
also ich bin ja normalerweise, chat, ich bin ja normalerweise nicht schadenfroh und ich
kenn den Carl auch nett und ich hab da absolut keinen Bezug zu, aber ich kann das halt nur
an der Sache beurteilen, was auf YouTube so abgeht, aber ich bin ja normalerweise nicht
schadenfroh, ne, aber in dem Fall find ich's durchaus gerechtfertigt, dass er keine Aufrufe
mehr hat, du musst, genau, du musst skalieren, musst du, ja, ja, und die Basics machen,
das hab ich, die Basics muss man machen, das hab ich auch schon gelernt, die Basics
ist ganz wichtig, ja, ja, wenn man die Basics nicht macht, dann ist, dann ist was, dann
ist was kaputt, ja, Computer Explo, sorry Leute, ich muss mal kurz angucken, ich will
jetzt eigentlich gar kein YouTube gucken, aber, Moment, das haben wir schon gesehen, ist das,
ist das die Knipex Rohrzange, ist das, ist das die gute Knipex mit einer Hand verstellbare
Rohrzange, die ist richtig Pock, Knippchamp, ja, ey, die ist Massive Pock, ich weiß, ich
mach, man könnte fast denken, ich bin gesponsort, aber die ist wirklich gut, die ist wirklich
gut, wieder, die ist richtig Pock, die kann man nämlich mit einer Hand verstellen, stufenlos
mit einer Hand verstellen, so, flupp flupp, richtig nice, eine richtig nice Rohrzange.
So, also Leute, ihr seht es ja im Titel, heute ist eigentlich gar kein Stream, aber
ich bin gerade, ich war gerade, bevor ich hier angemacht habe, ich war gerade am Überlegen
für ein neues, für ein neues Video, und zwar, ich will ein Video machen, oh, was habe ich
denn hier auf, ich will ein neues Video machen, weil, das, das machen gerade, das machen gerade,
das ist gerade angesagt, ja, und ich hab mir gedacht, ich mach das auch mal, zu meiner
letzter Zeit so viele Leute, auch Technik-Scheiß-Kommenten bei mir auf YouTube, was ich Massive Pock aus
finde, und zwar, ich wollte ein Video machen, ich weiß aber nicht, wie ich, denn vielleicht
hat da jemand von euch eine Big-Brain-Idee im Chat, ja, ich wollte, ich wollte so was
machen wie, ja, so nach dem Motto, welche, welche Technologien man lernen sollte.
Ja, also, ich kann halt schreiben, ihr wisst, was ich meine, ja, also, was man, was man
lernen sollte, so, und, oder, beziehungsweise, wovon ich denke, dass das relevant ist, und
ich brauch da...
Das kommt als nächstes ab, ab, oder was, Adder, so, Fax, ja, also, ich bin, und ich
bin draufgekommen, also, eine Sache, die auf jeden Fall relevant wird, ist WebAssembly
mit WebGPU, so, dann hab ich noch, auf jeden Fall ganze AI-Zeug-Piecen, sollte man auch
wissen, oder wenn man, wenn man, wenn man da mit was machen will, Fortran, Alter, Leute,
nach wie vor, Kubernetes-Kram, ich kann es halt mal schreiben, Kubernetes, Placer glaube
ich nicht, Tanser, ich glaube nicht, dass, ich glaube überhaupt nicht, dass Placer groß
rauskommen wird, zumindest nicht in den nächsten 5 Jahren, Placer ist eine richtig geile Idee,
also wer das nicht kennt, ich muss mal kurz zeigen, was da Microsoft zu sagt, Placer ist
quasi eine.NET-Runtime in WebAssembly, wo man C-Sharp im Browser machen kann, das Problem
ist nur, das Problem ist nur, dass, dass ewig Dauer bis runtergeladen ist und du viele Sachen
da drin nicht machen kannst, die mit JavaScript easy sind, also das ist, das würde ich sagen,
Docker ist jetzt schon nicht mehr die Zukunft, Docker hat eigentlich ziemlich reingeschissen
in letzter Zeit, aber so als, ähm, Kommandozeilen kleint, wird das wahrscheinlich weiterhin
recht beliebt bleiben, was ist Bosq, Bosq, was für ein Ding, Alter, was ist mit der
Musik los, was ist Bosq, was, Microsoft, was für ein Ding, was zum Teufel ist das,
was geht jetzt eigentlich mit der Musik gerade ab, was ist, wie spricht man, Alter, wie
spricht man, also ich mag Programmiersprache, ich mag Technologien nicht, die man nicht
aussprechen kann, wie soll man denn Bosq, Bosq, Bosq, Bosq aussprechen, Bosq, Bosq,
das Bosq, wisst ihr, wie sich das anhört, das hört sich an wie irgendein kroatisches
Fleischgericht oder sowas, Bosq, so in der Richtung, so also was ist das, ich hab da
vorne nie was gehört, Alter, Alter, die Musik, was ist denn gerade los hier, wo hab ich die
Musik überhaupt an, okay, das kenn ich nicht, haben die, haben die Beispiel, examples, add
to numbers, ah, jetzt dafür muss ich natürlich eine neue Programmiersprache finden, nein,
natürlich nicht, da kannst du damit noch mehr machen, F-Sternchen ist immer schlimmer,
die Musik ist leicht, wie sagt man heutzutage, belastend, hast du von Q-Sharp schon mal,
nein, auch nicht, ich scheine, ich bin überhaupt nicht mehr auf dem aktuellen Stand, was sowas
angeht hier, oh, falsches Emote, Alter, ich hab, ich hab dieses Emote direkt überhalb
von, also es kann, es kann durchaus sein, dass wenn ich drücken will, dass ich anstatt
zu drücken aus Versehen drücke, übrigens wisst ihr was auch noch unbedingt Leute, wisst
ihr was mir einfällt, was unbedingt noch ins Board rein muss, aber, aber ganz, ganz wichtig,
die Oma, die Oma da muss rein, die Oma da muss rein, ich kann mich da immer, wie die
das ausspricht, ich kann mich da immer am Bein kaputtladen, die Oma ist so geil, Fick dich
weg, du Hobo-Fürst, die Linie 140 hat ja angeblich Verspätung, Fick dich weg, du Hobo-Fürst,
ich finde das so geil, übrigens, drei Mal dürft ihr raten von wem ich das hab, ratet
mal von wem ich das hab, ich kannte das gar nicht, kommt da nie drauf, von wem, klar von
dem sonst Null, vom Weihnachtsgriller, vom Weihnachtsgriller hab ich das nicht, erstes
als Weihnachtsgriller glaube ich schon zwei Jahre her und die guckt sich sowas wahrscheinlich
nicht an, ok also, YouTube-DL, muss man gerade mal kurz ins Board aufnehmen, ganz, ganz
wichtig, ab wie viel Sekunden geht es denn los, die Linie 140 hat ja angeblich Verspätung,
bei sechs Sekunden geht es los, alles klar, ok, also, Fick dich weg, du Hobo-Fürst, benennen
wir das mal kurz um, jetzt wollen wir wieder FFmpeg Videos schneiden, das findet der Chat
ja auch immer toll, FFmpeg, FFmpeg, Input, wir müssen jetzt den Waff draus machen, Input,
so, und das ganze wollen wir schneiden bei sechs Sekunden und dann nennen wir es Waff,
gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert hat, fast oder, passt eigentlich ganz gut, aber vielleicht
sollten wir es noch eine Sekunde später machen, ah es reicht nicht, ok, ok Leute, hm, wie
macht man da die Hälfte, das hab ich noch nie gemacht, kann man 6,5 machen, oh das geht,
Big Brain, das geht, das wusste ich gar nicht, dass man 0,6,5 machen kann, Alter Massive
6 hat er, ok das passt, Fick dich weg, du Hobo-Fürst, Fick dich, jawoll, Fick dich weg,
du Hobo-Fürst, sehr gut, das brauchen wir als E-Mode, ganz, ganz furchtbar wichtig,
so, hm, gut, da kann man das hier wieder zumachen, warum muss das Waff sein, es muss kein Waff
sein, es muss irgendwas sein, was der Browser-Native abspielen kann, es muss kein Waff sein, ich
glaube Browser kann mittlerweile, was kannst du, ok, ok, verwende doch irgendjemand, ok,
den Vodafone-Button, was denn, soll ich drücken, hier den da, bei sieht besser aus, wenn ich
das nicht auf diesem Ding, den da, wobei ich ja ganz ehrlich, das Telecom-E-Mode ist immer
noch das beste in der Richtung hier, Pains-Champ-Telecom, und ganz ehrlich, wir haben Big Brain-Mods,
weil das Bild hat auch ein Mod erstellt, ich weiß, nee, also, ganz ehrlich, so teuer wie
aktuell gerade Hardware ist, würde ich auf die Mehrwertesteuer scheißen und das nächstes
Jahr kaufen, das Zeug kostet halt gerade ein Viertel mehr, da bringt es die Mehrwertsteuer
nur wirklich nicht, also was, Bosque, warum ist das überhaupt hell, ich will das Dark
Realm, jawoll, ok, also, das ist, sieht aus wie Javascript, ah nee, es ist, doch, es ist
quasi Javascript mit Types, das ist quasi wie Typescript, warum, warum, warum, warum
brauchen wir da was Neues, warum brauchen wir da was Neues, witter, diesmal den ersten
Satz, Inspired by the Syntax and Types of Types, Typescript, ja, aber es gibt doch
schon Typescript, warum brauche ich da wieder was Neues, oh, die, die File-Extension ist
gut, Bosque, Bosque, soll man das aussprechen, Bosque, wir machen den zweiten Satz, Design
Golf for language includes better software quality and improved developer productivity,
ja, das sagen sie alle, ok, mal abwarten, habe ich aber noch nicht gehört von, scheint
aber geht, ich sage mal, habt ihr auch, ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass Microsoft, seit
so, im Prinzip seit der neue CEO am Start ist, ich sage mal, ein, zwei Jahre danach,
Microsoft ist von übelst gehatet, alles macht sich lustig über Microsoft, hat sich komplett
180 Grad gewandelt von Microsoft, die Scheiße, jeder findet geil, was Microsoft macht mittlerweile,
früher war Microsoft zu Ballmer Zeiten, war so Lul, Microsoft, Shit, Windows und alles
mögliche Sache und jetzt ist alles, oh, Pock, Microsoft, allerdings muss man halt auch sagen,
Microsoft macht halt auch viel gutes Zeug mittlerweile, es gibt halt noch ein paar Sachen,
die scheiße sind, sowas wie zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, das Windows 10 Settings Menü,
das ist halt kacke, aber generell ist halt vieles, geh weg Windows, letztens hat mich
in den Comments einer gefragt, was, warum ich so viel mit Linux machen würde, warum
nicht Windows und das war jemand, also der konnte ich jetzt keine große, das war halt
eindeutig jemand in den Comments, wo du jetzt nicht mit Technik Sachen kommen musst und
da ist mir spontan eigentlich, finde ich zumindest, eine recht gute Erklärung eingefallen, warum,
und zwar, weil Linux in der Regel das macht, was man erwartet und Windows nicht, aber Windows
kann es durchaus sein, dass man irgendeine Option anschaltet und halbes Jahr später
hat die sich automatisch wieder ausgeschaltet, es ist nicht so, dass Linux immer logisch
ist, das ist auf gar keinen Fall, ja, also gerade hier so Sachen, wie Minus, Minus Version,
ist es Minus V, ist es Minus Version, ist es Minus, Minus V, Minus V, was auch immer,
es ist auch ziemlich, ziemlich schwer, ja, keine, what the fuck, ganz schön, dass man
das nicht löschen kann, wenn das hier weg ist, ah, oh ist das neu, oh das ist ja Massive
Brained, da kann ich löschen, ne jetzt löscht, ach was auch immer, aber das ist halt der große
Unterschied für mich, ja, in der Regel kannst du dich bei Linux darauf verlassen, was es
macht, also dass es sich irgendwie nachvollziehbar verhält, wenn du es einmal gemacht hast, was
halt bei Windows nicht der Fall ist, und was bei Windows Server auch nicht der Fall ist,
ja, PowerShell, PowerShell ist auch ein gutes Beispiel, PowerShell gibt es ja mittlerweile
sogar für Linux, guck mal, ich kann PowerShell hier installieren, wenn ich will, habe ich
nicht, weil ich mich ehrlich gesagt frage, was ich damit machen soll, aber PowerShell
ist echt gut, PowerShell ist echt gut, PowerShell ist, finde ich, eine scheiß interaktive Shell,
aber PowerShell ist für Betriebssystem, Automatisierung, Sachen, und gerade für Windows, wo ja zigtausend
Interfaces und Sachen gibt, oder irgendwelche nicht dokumentierten Registry-Dinger, ist
das ein Segen, PowerShell, ja, also für Automatisierung und Scriptingsachen ist PowerShell super,
ich gehe sogar so weit und sage, wenn man ausreichend, also wenn man wirklich recht
komplexe Sachen scriptet, dann würde ich sogar sagen, da ist potentiell PowerShell, PowerShell
besser als Bash, Bash ist halt, Bash hat eine Syntax aus der Hölle und gut die PowerShell
Syntax ist auch nicht sehr der Wahnsinn, aber Bash hat eine uralt Syntax vom letzten Jahrtausend
und in Bash ist alles Text und der große Vorteil von PowerShell ist, es hat eine busy modernere
Syntax und es ist nicht Text, sondern das sind ganz normale.NET-Objekte drunter, das
heißt potentiell ist PowerShell für, so komplexer die Sachen werden, umso besser geeignet, ja,
was mit Bosk ist, ja, keine Ahnung, fick die Schweck du Homo-Fürst, äh, wie bin ich jetzt
überhaupt zu diesem ganzen Kram gekommen, ich wollte euch eigentlich irgendwas erzählen,
Chat, was wollte ich euch denn erzählen, ich wollte euch irgendwas erzählen, habe ich voll
mega sidetracked, VSCode, nee, was VSCode wollte, nein, ich wollte, VSCode, achso, das,
ja nee, aber ich wollte euch noch irgendwas anderes erzählen, die Logos von Microsoft
sind hässlich, ja, die sollten sich mal auf Fiverr ein paar indische Grafikdesigner holen
und sich das machen lassen, guckt euch mal an, ja, robot, der ist mega hässlich,.NET-Core,
der.NET-Roboter, ja, der sieht wirklich kacke aus, ja, guckt mal, äh, wer hat das Ding
designt, das ist richtig, richtig eklig, PowerShell-Logo kenne ich überhaupt nicht, was ist denn das
PowerShell-Logo, sieht aus wie aus Cyberpunk, äh, es erinnert mich an zwei Sachen, erinnert
mich an Cyberpunk-Charakter oder an Sombra aus Overwatch, hat doch was, müsst ihr zugeben,
es hat eine gewisse Ähnlichkeit, oder, sagt doch mal, also, könnt durchaus inspiriert
gewesen sein davon, die neuen Google-Logos sind auch Mist, Leute, Google hat mich heute
wieder so hart gebadet, ich, mich fuckt das mittlerweile so ab, wenn man Mobile-Sachen
funktionsbeschränkt, ihr kennt das ja, wenn man auf Google-Docs geht, ähm, gehen wir
mal dahin, einfach nur, weil ich es gerade in der Historie habe, das ist das, äh, Garten-Layout
von der letzten Person of Exile-League, hat überhaupt nichts mit dem zu tun, was ich erzählen
wollte, so, und normalerweise kann man ja, wenn man, wenn Google, Leute, wir haben jetzt
ein Emote verliegt, macht mal, macht mal, wupp, Leak, wir haben jetzt ein extra Emote
dafür, oh, come on, das ist gut hier, gespiegelter, gespiegelter Spiegel, so, also, ich will euch
dieses, normalerweise kann man ja, wenn man einen Link geshared bekommt, den man editieren
darf, kann man die Seite einfach aufmachen, ohne sich rein, ohne reinzuklicken, und kann
er hier drin schreiben, so, ich hab nen Google-Doc-Dokument gemacht, für nen Video, was ich aufnehmen
will, hab das mit jemandem geshared, mit dem ich das Video aufnehmen will, und dann hat
er sich das angeguckt, wollte was reinschreiben, und ich eben, und mir ist unterwegs eingefallen,
ah, ich schreib auch nochmal was rein, bin in Twitter, in die private messages, hab den
shared link aufgemacht, weil ich mobile bearbeiten wollte, geht das Dokument auf, in Google-Docs,
und hat oben rechts, so richtig, richtig gebait, hat oben rechts den bearbeiten Knopf, und
dann gehst du auf den bearbeiten Knopf, und dann sagt's, nee, du musst die Google-Docs-App
runterladen, und dann hab ich die Google-Docs-App, also man konnte gar nicht bearbeiten, obwohl
der bearbeiten Knopf da ist, und dann hab ich, dann hab ich die Google-Docs-App runtergeladen,
ich wollte dieses Ding öffnen in der Google-Docs-App, und dann hat die Google-Docs-App gesagt,
nee, geht nicht, muss ich erst anmelden, wozu hab ich denn dann anonymen gescherte Links?
Alter, das ist so dumm, das ist so dumm, diese funktion, diese sinnlose Funktionsbeschränkung
von Mobile-Anwendung, um ihre Apps unter die Leute zu bringen, das ist so dumm, das regt
mich an total vielen Stellen auf, Google-Docs ist nicht das einzige, Mobile-Plaps, ja, richtige
Mobile-Plats, True-Story, True-Lull-W, aber sowas von, so, ok, kommen wir mal zu dem hier
zurück, ich guck jetzt erstmal noch schnell in den Chat rein, weil ich hab bestimmt wieder
Wubbel, Wubbelorts, bestimmt wieder Zeug übersehen, bitter shit, so, exellent, das
kenn ich, das ist Python auf Java-Base, es gibt auch JRuby, übrigens, das ist ein Ding,
das wollte ich, da war ich mir nicht sicher, ob ich das reinschreiben soll, weil es gibt
seit gestern Ruby 3, Ruby, kann sich da noch einer dran erinnern, ich hab hier die Sache
schon mal erzählt, hier im Stream, hab ich, kennt ihr die Ruby-Story schon, don't cry
so much, würdest du Beamerlampen für 8 Euro auf Aliexpress kaufen statt das Original 75
Euro, ja, also, ich, für alle die nicht dabei waren, ich erzähl's noch mal kurz, und zwar,
also, um jetzt die eine Sache noch mal abzuschließen, es kam gestern oder, nee, vor, hier, an Weihnachten
oder so, kam Ruby 3 raus, ich bin ja großer Ruby-Fan, was die Programmiersprache angeht,
ich, ich hab da so meine Hoffnung, dass das 2021 wieder gut abgeht, also, ich benutze
mal ein Jaro mit E3-WM, ich würd sagen, wenn man ein bisschen Vorkenntnisse hat und gerne
bastelt, ist das gut, aber für komplette Neueinsteiger, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht
nicht direkt, Ubuntu Desktop mag ich nicht, also, für komplette Neueinsteiger würde ich
dir Linux Mint empfehlen, Elementary, wenn du Mac magst oder, wenn dich China nicht abschreckt,
auch Deepin.
So, also, was ich euch erzählen wollte, also, ich muss dazu mal ein Bild von einem Gnome-Desktop
aufmachen, weil ich hab kein Gnome-Desktop hier, so sieht das Ganze aus, so, also, wir
hatten einen Kollege auf der Arbeit, äh, Sneaky Boy kann ich dir gleich erzählen, ähm,
wir hatten einen Kollege auf der Arbeit, den haben wir eingekauft für ZFS, wir wollten
damals nämlich Solaris mit ZFS machen, haben wir uns so überlegt, da haben wir uns jemand
eingekauft, der sollte Solaris mit ZFS machen, und als der Typ dann da angefangen hat bei
uns, haben wir uns überlegt, nein, wir machen doch kein Solaris mit ZFS, und dann saß dieser
Typ dann da, und hat im Endeffekt nichts zu tun, und der ist mit der Zeit immer weiter
durchgedreht im Kopf.
Ich glaub, der war auch schon nicht so, ich glaub, der war auch so schon nicht mehr ganz
dicht, und man hat ihn dann halt auch noch Sachen machen lassen, weil, ich mein, der
war halt teuer, teuer, externer, äh, Typ, ja, also der hat wahrscheinlich 150k im Jahr
oder so heimgetragen, Material oder Bootstrap, mittlerweile fast schon Bootstrap, Material
Design ist das neue Bootstrap, äh, und da haben sie ihm dann auch immer Aufgaben gegeben,
wo er keine Ahnung hatte, keinen Bock drauf hatte, so, und zumindest haben sie ihm die
Aufgaben halt gegeben, er soll Puppet-Code programmieren, ja, das ist so ein Server-Automatisierungs-Tool,
ist jetzt auch egal, was das macht, zumindest saß der dann halt manchmal vor seinem Gnome-Desktop,
das sah dann halt ungefähr so aus, ja, und Puppet ist ja in Ruby programmiert, und das
kam dann manchmal vor, wenn's ruhig war im Büro, dass der vor seinem Rechner gesessen
hat, hat ein bisschen Puppet gemacht, und hat dann vor sich hin ab und zu mal einfach so
random in den Raum gesagt, Ruby, Ruby, richtig hängen geblieben, richtig hängen geblieben,
und dann kam das Schlimmste, und dann kam das Schlimmste, das Schlimmste, ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht, wie man das macht, ich hab keine Ahnung, wirklich, ich weiß nicht, wie man
das macht, er hat sein Notebook so eingestellt, dass der PC-Speaker summt, wenn er mit der
Mauszeige an den Bildschirmrand gekommen ist, und das war dann eine echt geile Kombination,
der hat dann vom Rechner gesetzen, und hat, ich weiß nicht, wie man das einstellt, keine
Ahnung, der hat dann ab und, der hat dann vom Rechner gesessen, Ruby, und dann später
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, zwei Minuten später, ist er dann mit dem Rechner an den Bildschirmrand
gekommen, und da hat der PC, also hat er dann so gemacht, PC-Speaker hat er gemacht, und
daraufhin hat er dann immer gesagt, der scheiß Gnome, und die Kombination war dann manchmal,
dass er vom Rechner gesessen hat, Ruby, und dann hat es später, der scheiß Gnome, und
das in Kombination, das hat sich bei mir eingebrannt, der ist wirklich mit der Zeit langsam durchgedreht
bei uns, ich weiß wirklich nicht, wie man das einstellt, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie
man sowas, dass der PC-Speaker angeht, wenn du mit der Maus an den Rand kommst, also ich
wollte irgendwas vom Sneaky Boy beantworten, habe ich gesagt, ne, die Geschichte gefällt
dem Chat, das weiß ich, also, wie hast du Windows und Linux gleichzeitig laufen, ganz
einfach, ich habe Windows laufen, als Host, also ganz normal Windows, so wie du auch Windows
installieren würdest, und dann habe ich Forever Workstation installiert, und in Forever Workstation
kann man quasi noch weitere Betriebssysteme laufen lassen, parallel, das ist quasi ein
Rechner im Rechner, was hältst du von Heftor Linux, kenne ich nicht, sagt mir überhaupt
nichts, soll ich mal gucken, wie das aussieht, Heftor, ist das eine Tordistro, wo die besonders
anonym ist, oder was, wie findest du WSL, das beste, was du unter Windows machen kannst,
wenn du ordentlich arbeiten willst, und kein Linux vor allem verwenden kannst, was hältst
du von Hello Kitty Linux, was hältst du von Hannah Montana Linux, kommt als nächstes,
also was ist Heftor Linux, Designed for Style and Stability, Leute, den Linux Leuten, ich
glaub dir nix mehr, also ganz ehrlich, die meisten Distros, die stylisch sind, die haben
ein schickes Startmenü und ein schönes Hintergrundbild, und der Rest passt überhaupt nicht zusammen,
die einzigen, es gibt zwei Distros, die das wirklich ganz gut hinbekommen, das ist also
meiner Ansicht nach, immer nur, also kann ja jeder verwenden, was er will, aber meiner
Meinung nach gibt es nur zwei Distros, die das wirklich halbwegs konsequent, konsistent
hinbekommen, es gibt Deepin Linux, das ist der China Linux, das haben wir hier auch schon
im Stream ausprobiert, das ist relativ konsistent, stylisch und gleich stylisch gemacht, das
ist ganz gut, ist zwar im Prinzip unter der Haube auch nur eine Gnome Shell, aber ist ok,
und Elementary OS, wobei ich Deepin deutlich besser finde von der GUI als Elementary, ja,
Elementary ist für Leute, die Mac mögen, und gleichermaßen die Philosophie von Apple
auch mögen, so wie wir sagen, dass es sein muss, so ist es gottgegeben, korrekt, das
muss man ja als Apple Fan, ja, und in manchen Bereichen finde ich das auch gerechtfertigt
und gut, aber in manchen halt auch gar nicht, ja, also Elementary kriegt das auch ganz gut
hin, so aber was ist Heftal Linux, das können wir eigentlich mal, theoretisch können wir
sogar heute ausprobieren, Adopt a Cool Penguin, Alter was ist das, das ist ja cringe, Alter,
Pain's Champ, Ghetto Linux, Pain's Champ, ok, was macht das denn jetzt aus, was sagt,
gibt es da irgendwie News Artikel oder so, Computer Base, Linux Augensprache in 6.
Edition, in 6 Editionen, ok, ich lad mal, also was kam denn, oh, ach du Scheiße, das
verwendet wirklich jemand, und Herbstluft, Alter, ok, die wollen es aber schon mal wissen,
das ist echt ausgefallen, das ist wirklich ausgefallen, da weiß ich gar nicht wie man
das ausspricht, BISP WM, und das ist glaube ich Herbstluft WM, das ist zwei absolut Nischen
Dinger, das verwendet kaum einer, aber das ist schon mal abgedreht, abgedreht, ja, und
dann haben wir Screenshots, die irgendwie 300 mal 300 sind, ich mein es wäre ja gut,
wenn man auch mal was drauf erkennt, ist KDE oder sowas, wir probieren mal die XFCE Variante
aus, komm, komm, wir probieren das, ich kann das mal nebenbei runterladen, wir haben ja
noch ne Stunde, wobei wir haben heute gerade Zeit, so Leute, ich glaube da haben wir gerade
Zeit für heute, ich kann es aber schon mal runterladen, download Iso, excellent, äh,
ja, naja, warum keine Zeit, weil ich wahrscheinlich schon noch ne Stunde on bin ungefähr, ja aber
Awesome WM gibt es nicht bei Heftor, Heftor's Linux, gibt es nur XFCE, Plasma, ist Plasma
so ne Art KDE, wahrscheinlich, äh, Herbstluft, Gnome und BISP WM, ich hab die letzten 10
Jahre an KDE mal verwendet, warum XFCE, naja, weil ich KDE nicht mag, weil ich Gnome auch
nicht so wirklich mag und die zwei Dinger hab ich noch nie verwendet, aber ich weiß,
dass das in die Richtung I3 geht und wahrscheinlich ein bisschen komplizierter ist, deswegen XFCE,
Musik wieder, das ist, das ist richtige Hackerman Musik gerade, SY 0XFF oder alternativ könnte
man natürlich auch sagen 0X1111111111111, excellent, ich hab jetzt die Eins nicht gezählt,
nicht gezählt, braucht weniger RAM als XFCE, ist doch so, zockst du aktuell noch irgendwas,
ja ich spiel, aktuell hab ich gerade vor ein paar Tagen mir das hier auf Steam gekauft,
aber auch schon mehr oder weniger durchgespielt, also für alle die Pokemon mögen ist das hier
Poggers Game, kann ich wirklich jedem nur empfehlen, eines der besten Games in dieser Richtung
der letzten Jahre, richtig massiv, so und dann spiel ich in letzter Zeit auch wieder
recht viel Battlefield 3, so, das hat der Friseur letztens gespielt, der Friseur hat
letztens fast Weltrekord gemacht im Stream, der hat gestern fast Weltrekord Arena gemacht,
ist nicht gerade Steam Winter Sale, ist nicht gerade Sale, es gibt doch, aber da gibt's
eh nix, das sagt Steam Sale ist genauso wie Amazon Prime, äh nicht Amazon Prime, ähm
Black Friday, wo es auch von 50.000 Sachen 5 gute Sachen gibt, lohnt sich, lohnt sich
überhaupt nicht, so, genau, so, wie gesagt ich wollte ja noch ein paar Sachen im Chat
beantworten, ich hab wieder voll, ich scroll einfach mal offscreen über den Chat drüber
und dann machen wir mal kurz hier die Sache weiter, also, Videokunst und Steam Sales 2022
ja, ist echt das letzte Jahr auch nicht, macht ihr vielleicht im nächsten Mal wieder
ein Video, ja, machen wir, haben wir schon, haben wir schon geplant.
Das Welt, wenn's ums Webdesign geht, ja, wobei ich mir da ganz ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher
bin, ich find's cool, ich hab selbst noch nix mitgemacht, großartig, ich find's von
der Idee her cool, aber ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, ob Nebar, React, Angular und
View da noch irgendwie Platz ist und natürlich, und natürlich JQuery, ähm, ich muss mal
kurz Chat durchscrollen, ich hab nämlich bestimmt ein paar Sachen über 10.
Einer der vielen Konstanten im Leben, Max ist ab 10 off, ne, eine Viertelstunde länger
geht, ich hab Urlaub, dann ist vorbei, vielleicht was für Sonntag Nachmittag, ja, das stimmt,
können wir, Schreib ich mir mal auf, schreib ich mir mal auf, bester Desktop.
Heftor Linux, das probier mal aus, die Tage, so, ich roll mal kurz weiter Chat, äh, der
Watosch sagt, BS, PWM seh ich auch auf Unix-Porn öfters mal, ja, auf Unix-Porn geht's ja
um zwei Sachen, erstens, möglichst die nichigste der Nischen-Softwares verwenden und die da
noch in 8-Bit-Farben-Stylish zu designen, dann kriegst du nen Top-Post auf Unix-Porn.
Ja, das ist, ähm, like a phoenix, das überrascht manche Leute auch immer, die mit E3 anfangen,
erstens ist es erstmal schwierig sich an Tiling, Tiling-Window-Manager ein bisschen
zu gewöhnen, aber wenn ich den Leuten dann sage, ey guck mal, du kannst auch, jetzt
hier erkennt man es nicht richtig, du kannst doch einfach ein Fenster floaten lassen, dann
sind sie komplett mindblown und wissen gar nicht was abgeht.
Oh, ich hab nen Zap übersehen, txzigend, alles klar, danke schön, Prime-Subscription,
Massive, neue Emotes, ja ja, wir haben neue Emotes, Seekiboy, so sieht's aus.
Ja, Captain Peng, das Problem ist nur, bei uns auf der Arbeit, äh, haben sie uns angedroht,
wir sollen alle Windows verwenden, als, als, als Leute, die über 4000 Linux-Server administrieren.
Warum denn, ja das weiß keiner so genau.
Sebiha, ist neu hier, hallo, ich scroll grad nur schnell den Chat drüber.
Zeig mal dein VS, V-Cinder-Profile, nee, kein Reveal ausstehen.
CheesyPro36v2, was mit V1 passiert, danke schön für den Zap, hab ich auch nicht gesehen.
Lieber das Native Kubernetes WebUI oder Ranger, das Native Kubernetes WebUI, um so wenige
extra Kram ernähren muss, um so besser, kommt aber immer auf den Anwendungszweck an.
Ja, 1-3-3-7 hat Recht, er hat geschrieben und dann kommt Max und sagt, keck weh und
null weh, ja ich sag das teilweise im echten Leben auch, ich hab's euch hier letztens erzählt,
ich hab im Bad gestanden und hatte zwei falsche Socken an und dann hab ich runter geguckt
zu mir und hab gesagt, keck weh, einfach komplett emotionslos hab ich gesagt, keck
weh, dann hab ich die Socken gewechselt.
SilverDark, für 8 Monate, danke schön für die Subs-Massive, plus 1 IQ Subscription.
Captain Peng, da saß rum und hat dafür Geld bekommen, ja so ist das halt, wenn man als
externer Experte eingekauft wird für ein Thema, was dann doch nicht gemacht wird.
Ja und Dro M, auf die Frage Material Design oder Bootstrap, da fragen wir jetzt mal den
Chat, da fragen wir jetzt mal den Chat, also Material Design kennen die alle, das ist
das Zeug, was auf Android, so die Android-Optik, sieht dann so aus, also die Webseiten sehen
dann so aus hier, ne, so, oder, ne mal eben die ordentliche Demo, da gibt's zwar eine
schöne Demo für Material Design, pff, sieht alles kacke aus, Alter, WTF, haben die keine
gescheite Demos sein, ja so sehen dann ungefähr Webseiten aus, oh, Helmer, also Material Design
so wie halt Android-Apps aussehen, so, versus Bootstrap und Bootstrap sieht ja halt so aus,
Bootstrap kennt auch wahrscheinlich jeder von der Optik, das sind zwei relativ verbreitete
Sachen, so und Chat, jetzt mal so die Frage an euch, so ist das Bootstrap-Geschichte,
was ist euch lieber, Material Design-Look oder Bootstrap, Twitch-Umfragen, ah Moment, wir
haben doch sowas hier, ach du Scheiß, wie geht das, Moment, Moment, wir machen Umfragen,
wir machen Massive-Umfragen, ich weiß gar nicht wie das geht, ah ne, ich bin ja nicht
eingeloggt, Moment, wie macht man denn, wie macht man das überhaupt, ich weiß gar nicht,
ich weiß gar nicht wie das funktioniert, wie im Moment, weil, Chat, wir müssen kurz
warten, ich muss Umfrage machen, how to create Twitch-Poll, alles klar, das machen wir jetzt,
es geht alle, ja, ja, ja, okay, okay, ach so, das ist alles,
ja, ja, ist okay, wir machen jetzt mal Abstimmung, das ist ja geil, Leute, man
kann Bits Chebaten, man kann Bits Chebaten, ich könnte sagen, wenn man doppelt abstimmen
muss, muss man mindestens 100 Bits spenden, das ist ja Chebat, Alter, okay, mal gucken,
ob das jetzt funktioniert, also, Chat, Material Design oder Bootstrap, Endless Money Clip,
also was gefällt euch persönlich besser ist, unabhängig davon, ne, wie man es einsetzen
kann, einfach was euch, was euch ist, wie es euch danach ist, oh Material Design, das hätte
ich gar nicht erwartet jetzt, normalerweise, muss man jetzt sagen, ich bin ja meistens,
meistens mit dem Chat so auf einer Wellenlänge, was das angeht, kann man so, kann man das
auch machen, also, ich muss sagen, bei mir sieht es so aus, das glaubt, das läuft noch
eine Minute, das sag ich mal kurz, also, bei mir sieht es so aus, ich verwende gern Vue.js
als Frontend und ich mag Vue.ify als Framework, dementsprechend mache ich relativ viel, wenn
ich was mache, in Material Design, sieht dann halt so, sehen halt Anwendungen aus, aber
ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, von der Optik her, mag ich Bootstrap deutlich lieber, das
Problem ist nämlich an Material Design, das Material Design ist das neue Bootstrap, du
wirst an jeder Ecke vollgeschissen mit Material Design und ich finde, es gibt in Material
Design und das ist auch bei Android so, ein paar Sachen, die ich absolut Haare sträuben
schlecht finde, zum Beispiel, der Date Picker, also, welches Superhirn sich das Ding bei
Google ausgedacht hat, weiß ich, äh, nicht der Date Picker, Time Picker, der Time Picker,
also welches Superhirn sich das Ding ausgedacht hat bei Google weiß ich auch nicht, was ist
denn das hier, Alter, ich krieg da jedes Mal Anfälle, wenn man das verwenden muss, also
dann ist mir der Apple Style Time Picker doch deutlich lieber, ich weiß, es gibt genug Leute,
die finden den gut, äh, also, das ist jedes Mal, also, wie gesagt, ich bin da, ich bin
da, äh, also, ich bin da zwar nicht allein, aber, äh, ich weiß, dass es viele auch anders
rum sehen, Pleasure 70, danke für den Zapp, jedes Mal, wenn ich mich, wenn ich mich da
drüber lustig mache, gibt's genug Leute, die sagen, die finden den geil und ich glaube,
das ist kein Gebate im Chat, ich glaube, die meisten, also, es gibt, viele Leute finden
den wirklich geil und da sieht man, so, gerade wenn es um solche Designsachen geht, es gibt
da nicht so eine Sache, die, die, äh, ultimativ ist, ja, aber ich mag den nicht, also, ich
mag den Material Design Date Picker nicht, ich find das Ding ultra hässlich, ich find's
scheiße zu bedienen und, ähm, überhaupt im, im Uhrdings- und im 24-Stunden-Modus ist
das Ganze übrigens noch ekeliger zu bedienen, ja, richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig Kokona-Sache
hier.
Da finde ich den Apple, Apple Style Time Picker viel besser, da kann ich jetzt so ein Bild
sein, den da, den finde ich so viel angenehmer, ganz ehrlich, den gibt's bestimmt, den gibt's
bestimmt auf GitHub nachbauten, also, auf Touch ist der Top am PC-Flop, äh, gibt's,
gibt es, gibt es irgendwie den Time Picker für JavaScript?
What the fuck, what, what, ey, okay, was, was gibt's, gibt's da eigentlich irgendwas
Gescheites? Time Picker GS, das sieht ja aus wie 1950, ey, geht noch nichtmal, ist einfach
kaputt, gibt's da nicht irgendwas Gescheites? Flat Picker, Demo, gibt's nicht, keine Demo,
Demo, wo ist denn die Demo? Demo, Usage, Examples, okay, das ist doch schon mal ganz
gut, ja, sowas ist hier, ja, und da finde ich sieht man wunderbar dran, dass man Desktop-Bedienung
und Touch-Bedienung nicht über einen, einen Kamm scheren sollte, weil einen Date Picker
am PC mit Maus und Tastatur kann man ganz anders machen als ein Date Picker mit Touch,
deswegen finde ich auf Touch den Android Date Picker wunderbar und auf dem PC finde ich
den Default Date Picker ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so übel. Was ist eigentlich mit Flat
und Metro Design passiert? Ja, ja, hier ist immer noch am Start, keine andere außer Microsoft
will's fangen, wie sieht eigentlich der Windows Time Picker aus? Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung
wo man den Windows Time Picken kann? Ja, den mag ich, der ist okay, nur dass er, nur dass
er kaputt ist, nur dass er kaputt ist, wenn er drauf, ey, diese Windows-UWP-Anwendungen,
die sind so dermaßen scheiße, die sind so schlecht, diese Dinger. Was zur Hölle, ist
ein Time Picker? Ja, das hier. Alter, das ist kaputt, ich glaub's nicht, ich hab den
Time Picker kaputt gemacht. Ein Time Picker ist das Ding, wo du auswählen kannst, an
welcher Uhrzeit was starten soll. Am PC ist es kein Ding, weil am PC kannst du einfach
die Uhrzeit eintragen, aber mobile braucht man sowas. By the way, warum ist der Time
Picker kaputt, nachdem ich da was eingetragen hab? Warum, warum sind diese Windows Default
Apps so unglaublich schlecht? Ich krieg jedes Mal wieder Anfälle, wenn stehen Krams, die
sind so schlecht, die Kalender-App ist kacke. Wenn der Cursor noch drin ist, geht das, ne,
der Cursor geht automatisch rein, wenn ich da draufklick. Ist einfach kaputt. So ein
Crap, Alter. Richtiger Müll. Also die Windows Default, also hier, Kalender-App ist kacke.
Windows Mail, richtiger Crap. Absoluter Müll. Was ist da noch standardmäßig dabei? Kennt
ihr gar nicht? Cortana 0W. Cortana, Alter. Kamera mach ich jetzt nicht auf, weil ihr
wisst, was passiert, wenn ich die Kamera aufmache. Die Foto-App ist auch richtig kacke. Richtig
mies, die Foto-App. Ähm, das weiß ich gar nicht, was das sein soll, was ist das überhaupt?
Ah, excellent, alles klar, brauchen wir nicht. Ah ja, die Windows 7 Foto-App, die war übrigens
beim Release noch dabei. Ich mein, was ist denn das hier eigentlich? Warum gibt's eigentlich
bei einem Bild, was du rechts anklickst, 50 Milliarden Optionen? Ich mein, Edit Photos,
Edit Paint 3D, Edit. Edit ist das normale Paint. Edit Paint 3D ist Paint 3D. Ich brauch
natürlich unbedingt Paint 3D, um Cac-W zu editieren, das ist ganz, ganz essentiell.
Ähm, und dann kann ich Edit mit Fotos machen. Und dann kann ich auch noch, sag mal, Create
3D. Video, was passiert denn dann? Und jetzt? New Video. Cac-W. Was will Microsoft von
mir jetzt haben? 3D Effects. What the fuck? Was passiert hier gerade?
Michael, du kriegst noch dein eigenes E-Mode. Du kriegst jetzt erstmal einen Sub gegiftet
von mir, weil du schon so lange am Start bist. 50 Billionen. Max spendiert heute. Ich habe
heute meine Gönjamin-Wochen, wie Kollege sagen würde. Meine Gönjamin-Wochen. Ist auch
so Cringe-Wort. Excellent. So. Was sind das vor allem für Sounds?
Lad das so auf YouTube, ja, ganz bestimmt. Alter, was ist das Scheiß? Sackt. Also, so
wie wir da beim Punkt sind, die, ähm, die Windows-Standard-Apps sind Müll.
Ey, ja klar, Michael, 50 Billionen, die wollen die Leute ja debaten, dass sie mehr Sub skiften,
mehr Geld für Amazon. Was hältst du von Flutter? Richtig geil? Ich hoffe nur, dass sie es hinkriegen,
dass es ordentlich auf dem Desktop mal funktioniert. Also, nicht nur irgendwie funktioniert, sondern
auch die notwendigen Sachen mitbringt, ja. Zum Beispiel, dass es einen ordentlichen Webview
hat und dass man auch 3D-Inhalte irgendwie reinkriegt, sei es mit OpenGL, X, Vulkan,
was auch immer. Am besten, dass man einfach mit was man will irgendwie in das Fenster
rendern darf. Und halt, dass es halt ordentlich auf allen Plattformen auf dem Desktop unterstützt
wird. Das heißt, Linux, Mac und Windows. Und DOS. Das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt habe,
gab es noch keinen Webview für Flutter auf dem Desktop. Was ist die Datei EA Bullshit?
Ich glaube, irgendeinen Bullshit-Bingo für eine Pressekonferenz oder so. Und anscheinend
haben wir ziemlich gut gelegen damit. Das war das Beste. Die hatten sie gleich am Start.
YouTuber C-Promis auf der Bühne. Ich glaube, dass sogar irgendeinen YouTuber oder C-Promi
die ganze Show präsentiert hat überhaupt von EA damals. Sinnloses Mobile-Game natürlich
auch. Battle Royale, klar. Pay2Win, wo sie nicht Pay2Win sagen. Free2Play. Aber ein Auto
auf der Bühne hatten sie nicht. Und einen merkwürdigen Need-for-Speed-Trailer hatten
sie nicht. Seht ihr mal, wie alt das schon ist. Battlefront 2 Schadensbegrenzung.
Taste, keine Ahnung. Übrigens, wenn man einen Bullshit-Bingo macht für alle, was immer
geht, ist Cringe. Einfach Cringe reinschreiben. Ihr könnt davon ausgehen, dass jegliche Präsentation
oder jegliche Pressekonferenz mindestens einen riesen Cringe-Moment hat. Okay, kommen wir
mal zu anderen Sachen zurück. Kann man web mit Ruby auch, hat vorhin TurboNautilus gefragt.
Kann man web mit Ruby auch ohne Ruby on Rails machen? Ja, das geht. Du kannst zum Beispiel
das da verwenden. Das ist so Mini-Web-Framework. Das war Vorbild für sehr viele andere Frameworks
in dieser Richtung. Das hat wirklich massig viele Frameworks inspiriert. Das ist ziemlich
simpel hier. Das war's. Mehr musst du nicht machen. Für Hello World Webseite. Wenn du
nur einfache Sachen brauchst, ist das nicht schlecht. Dann noch mal Chat runterscrollen
wieder. Schnell komm ich wieder her. Chat ist zu schnell heute. So. Hast du Tilted
Teams für ein gutes Mail-Programm? Verwende EMClient. Ja, EMClient ist ganz gut. Das habe
ich auch unter Windows verwendet. Ich verwende mittlerweile einfach für alles Thunderbird
und Gutes. Das ist zwar nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss, aber das Ding funktioniert
und ich meine, schön ist es nett. Generell muss man ja sagen, dass Firefox oder das ganze
Mozilla-UI seit ein paar Jahren kacke aussieht, aber das ist noch das, was am wenigsten nervt,
finde ich. Nachdem das Cross-Platform auch überall funktioniert, kann man machen. Muss
man aber nicht. Die Musik willst du jetzt wieder wissen, oder? Okay, kommen wir mal
zu der eigentlichen Sache zurück, wo ich mir erhofft habe. Der Chat hat noch ein paar
massive Ideen dafür. Kennst du Jupyter Notebooks? Ja, mache ich aber nichts mit. Kann ich dir
nichts zu empfehlen. Was sagst du zu Micro-Python? Richtig gute Sache, aber man kann damit zu
wenig machen auf dem ESP32. Deswegen greife ich trotzdem auf C++ zurück, auch wenn ich
C++ hasse wie sonst was. Opera-Browser gibt es keine Daseinsberechtigung mehr für. Wo
habe ich denn mein Visual Studio? Ja. Gibt es morgen einen Stream-Counter? Ich habe keine
Ahnung, weiß ich noch nicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich morgen mache. Weiß ich nicht,
ob ich überhaupt strebe. Wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich. Also, genau, ursprünglich
wollte ich mir eigentlich noch ein paar Ideen vom Chat holen, was für Technologien 2021
so voll abgehen werden. Also, wie gesagt, ich predikte, dass WebAssembly noch viel mehr
durch die Decke gehen wird, wie jetzt schon. Python und AI-Scheiß wird auf jeden Fall
Aja-Ja machen. Serverless mit Sicherheit, das ist eine gute Idee, ja. Und soll ich euch
mal das Geheimnis von Serverless verraten? Serverless sind genauso Server wie alles andere
auch. Deswegen funktioniert es. Man nennt das nur geiler. Ja, und man muss sich nicht
selbst darum kümmern, das ist ja der eigentliche Witz daran. JavaScript-Verlänger. JavaScript
will ich jetzt nicht drauf schreiben, weil JavaScript ist einfach die letzten Jahre schon
immer oben und damit kann man eigentlich rechnen. Bash Basics. Ja, aber das ist nichts für
2021, wo ich sagen würde, das ist jetzt irgendwie da was Neues, ja. Flutter. Ja, Flutter habe
ich mir auch schon aufgeschrieben. Richtig. Flutter. Flutter auf jeden Fall..NET. Ohne
Mist. Wann ich.NET 5 habe? Also, ich habe mir generell.NET aufgeschrieben. PWA weiß
ich nicht so genau. Das Problem an PWAs ist, dass Apple den Kram nicht richtig unterstützt.
Aber es ist verständlich, dass Apple den Kram nicht richtig unterstützt, weil die
wollen ja weiterhin Fett abkassieren im App Store. Und also, ich glaube,.NET wird wirklich
2021 noch weiter relevant werden mit.NET 5 und 6 und falls die wirkliches hinkriegen
Maui und WinUI was Gescheites zu basteln. Bis denn, Sebaro. Da habe ich aber meine Zweifel,
weil es Microsoft schon öfters verkackt hat, was UI angeht. Code Linearver. Das würde
ich drauf schreiben. Die Sache ist nur die. Davon habe ich überhaupt keine Ahnung und
kann ich null einschätzen. Erlang wird beliebt. Weinst du wirklich? Warum wird denn Erlang
beliebt, weil die Leute gerne Klammern machen oder wie? Also, das ist wahrscheinlich gültig
Erlangsundag vermute ich mal. Responsive Web Apps sind auch nichts Neues. In dem Sinne glaube
ich auch nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie so der Trend 2021 wird. Cobol. Der Chat, der hat
es mit Cobol. Ist der DB Welt irgendwas am Hypen? Ja, Fauna DB ist in der DB Welt am
Hypen. Oder Leute, ich bin nicht so der große DB Kerne, aber ich glaube Fauna DB ist voll
im Hype gerade. Kann das sein? Fauna DB. Ja, Mongo DB ist ja mittlerweile schon die
voll. Das ist voll angesagt. Habe ich gehört. Warum? Keine Ahnung. PHP? Nein, garantiert
nicht. Wobei PHP 8 jetzt rausgekommen ist. Und ich habe es euch ja schon angekündigt.
Wenn ich mal wirklich, wenn der Chat mal wieder irgendwas macht, was mir überhaupt
nicht gefällt, dann müsst ihr euch eineinhalb Stunden, da gehe ich einfach, gehe ich afk
und mache ich eineinhalb Stunden. Was ist neu in PHP 8 an? Scala? Ich weiß nicht. Gibt
es auch Flora DB? Ja, es gibt noch Fauna DB. Rust könnte sein. Nee, glaube ich nicht.
Rust ist zu Big Brain Sonntags. Rust ist geil, aber ich glaube Mainstream wird Rust im nächsten
Jahr nicht werden. Dann mache ich den Stream aus. Ja, hat keiner was davon. Java plus plus,
das fehlt jetzt noch. Zum Glück ist noch keiner auf die Idee gekommen, C++ und Java
irgendwie zu verbinden. Wobei, sag nie nie. Zum Glück nicht. Was immer alle gegen PHP
haben, ja nichts Wirksames. PHP ist insofern auch relevant, weil PHP bei jedem Furz-Hoster
unterstützt wird und mit Laravel mittlerweile auch erträglich ist. F sharp. Es wird seit
Jahren schon behauptet, dass, und ich habe das ja selbst vor ein paar Jahren auch gesagt,
dass funktionale Programmiersprachen immer so eine richtig große Mega-Hype wird. Es wurden
die letzten Jahre immer wieder kleine Hypes, aber so einen richtig riesen Boom an funktionalen
Programmiersprachen habe ich nicht gesehen. Ich glaube das liegt einfach daran, weil das
zu weit weg ist von dem, was die meisten Leute können und programmieren und sich für interessieren
und weil die meisten Leute auch zu smalles Brain haben für funktionale Programmiersprachen.
Ich auch. Nee, Go. Also Go wird 2021 genauso wie 2020 weiter relevant bleiben und sicherlich
auch wachsen, aber halt nichts wahnsinniges auslösen. Was soll denn Mopak S sein? Finde
ich, es ist eine gute Idee. Mopak S emote. Puck mit, nee, glaube ich nicht. Glaube ich
nicht. Leute, wir testen das mal. Wer von euch weiß, was Puck ist? Also es ist kein
Mops. Es hat was mit CSS zu tun. Kennt das hier, Mann? Siehste, deswegen sage ich, das
kennt kaum einer. Also wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, ja genau, wenn ich das
richtig in Erinnerung habe, ist Puck quasi ein Präprozessor für HTML oder sowas in
der Richtung. Hat aber, hat ein niedliches Maskottchen. Das ist schon mal das Allerwichtigste.
Nicht das Ding beim Eishockey. Hatten die nicht früher mal einen Mops mit Schleife,
weil das Maskottchen sieht doof aus. Glaube ich nicht, dass sich das durchsetzen wird,
und zwar aus dem gleichen Grund, warum sich die anderen HTML-Preprozessor-Dinger nicht
durchgesetzt haben. Weil man noch eine zusätzliche Sprache lernen muss für etwas, was an sich
schon ganz gut funktioniert. Dass es einfach aufhört, der nicht notwendig ist. Zumal er
auch dazu kommt, stell dir mal vor, du schreibst an HTML, schreibst du in Puck. So, und dann
hast du eine riesige Codebase an Puck. Und du kriegst den, du suchst neue Leute und keine
Sau kann Puck. Ich mein, du kannst dir das natürlich aneignen. Das geht wahrscheinlich
auch relativ schnell. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sich das durchsetzen wird. Gerade aus
diesen Gründen. By the way, wie funktioniert das hier eigentlich? Wie kann man hier Variablen
machen? Ja, also deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass sich das großartig durchsetzen wird.
Ich glaube kein HTML-Preprozessor-rumgewurste Ding wird sich großartig durchsetzen. Oh,
meine Augen. Ich muss kurz das Dark-Demon. Jawoll. Nee, das glaube ich nicht, dass ich
das durchsetzen werde. Habt ihr sonst noch irgendwas? Elektron für Desktop ist ja jetzt
schon. Ist ja jetzt schon. Ich meine Discord. Und ist nicht das einzige. Aber Typescript
ist auch schon. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das den wahnsinnigen Boom haben wird. Also
wie gesagt, ich denke, dass WebAssembly 2021 richtig abgehen wird. Das ist eigentlich so
meine Hauptprediction, was 2021 auf jeden Fall passieren wird. WebAssembly wird noch
viel mehr abgehen. Das ist ja jetzt zwar schon da, aber gerade die Möglichkeit, jetzt 3D-Anwendungen
machen zu können und noch mal zu portieren auf den Browser, dass wir 2021 auf jeden
Fall abgehen. Gerade Machine-Learning-Sachen wird 2021 auch richtig abgehen. Ganze Cloud-Container-Geschichte
wird 2021 auch noch mehr, also noch viel mehr abgehen. Ruby 3 hofft, ist ja mein persönlicher,
hoffe ich. Ich glaube nicht, dass das wirklich passieren wird, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich
hoffe es einfach mal. Ja, das ist übrigens eine Kategorie, jetzt können wir alles ins
Gleiche machen. Flutter, da bestehen die Chancen, wenn die wirklich, wenn die wirklich
schaffen, dass es auf dem Desktop gut funktioniert, dann, also, mein Apps, damit hat es ja angefangen,
aber dass es auch auf dem Desktop gut funktioniert und auch WebAssembly gut funktioniert, dann
könnte man das richtig gut vorstellen, dass es noch mehr abgeht. Ja, Ruby ist leider
fast ausgestorben. Auch Rails ist jetzt nicht mehr so der Rockstar-Shit. Aber nachdem jetzt
Ruby 3 rausgekommen ist und Ruby 3 ein paar richtig coole Sachen hat, ziemlich easy Multithreading,
so richtig Ruby-Style, ohne dass man jetzt auf viel achten muss und eine ganze Ecke
schneller ist, hoffe ich ja persönlich, dass 2021 so ein bisschen das Ruby-Ja wird und
Ruby wieder ein bisschen HIP wird. Ja, und Placer mit O, Plazor, Playsorts wird, glaube
ich, auch 2021 nicht abgehen. Auch, es ist zwar WebAssembly, aber warum sollte ich riesig
was downloaden, warum sollte ich den.NET Runtime downloaden für eine Webseite, wenn
ich das alles mit JavaScript machen kann und sogar noch schneller. Also, nee, glaube ich
nicht. Windows 11 wird bestimmt eine UI in Electron haben. Nee, Windows 11 wird es ja
nicht geben, weil es wird ja durch Linux ersetzt. Habt ihr den Artikel gesehen? Irgendein Typ,
irgendein Typ hat das letztens predicted. Irgendeiner hat gesagt, Windows wird, Microsoft wird Windows
durch Linux ersetzen. Und da hab ich mir auch so gedacht irgendwie. Ich weiß nicht, was
mit den Leuten los ist, man kann sich ja noch was wünschen, aber nee, das wird nicht passieren.
Meinst, oh, das ist eine gute Frage. Meinst du Cloud Gaming wird abgehen? Nein, glaube
ich nicht. Nee. Nee. Cloud Gaming ist so ein typisches Stonksting. Als Google Stadia angekündigt
hat, haben sie alle gesagt, oh fuck, Google macht Stadia, wir müssen mitmachen, wir brauchen
auch irgendwas. Und dann kam dann auf einmal sogar die Telekom um die Ecke und hat gedacht,
wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt Magenta Gaming, weil die Telekom bei jedem Scheiß
und jedem Hype mitmachen muss, den es gibt. Und es kommt da nichts gescheites raus. Amazon
macht auch ein Game Streaming Service und hast du nicht gesehen. Ich hab mir schon gedacht,
bei Stadia, naja, ob das mal was wird, ist ja nicht wirklich was geworden. Spielen passt,
es ist jetzt kein totaler Reihenfall, wie manche andere Google Sachen, aber es ist jetzt
nicht so der Wahnsinn geworden. Deswegen glaube ich auch nicht, dass, ja, GeForce Now ist
noch das Beste. Deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass Cloud Gaming 2021 nennenswert irgendwelche
Sprünge machen wird. Nee. Rust ist richtig geil, aber ich glaube es nicht. Was könnte
denn 2021 noch so richtig abgehen? Also, außer bei Ruby finde ich die Sachen eigentlich relativ
einleuchtend. Ruby würde ich mir einfach nur wünschen, dass das richtig abgeht. Aber
was könnte 2021 an Technologien noch richtig einschlagen? Was gibt es denn da noch? Was
ist denn aktuell angesagt? Was wir nicht schon gesagt haben? Was unvorhersehbares? Ja, gut,
das ist klar, das könnte mal sein. Club-Handys, ey, ohne Scheiß, man weiß nie. Es muss nur
der Richtige auf die Idee kommen, Club-Handys wieder zu promoten, ja. Also, wenn sich da
ein paar krasse Influencer-Dudes einig sind, dann sind auch Club-Handys wieder im Trend.
Corona-Mutation, ja, das kommt wahrscheinlich eh schon. AV1? Das könnte tatsächlich sogar
sein, ja. Das könnte wirklich sein, ja. Aber das wird auch alles nennenswerte Verbreitung
erst erfahren, wenn es ordentliche Hardware-Decoder gibt, auch für kleine Geräte. Das ist ja gerade
das Gute an H.264. Jedes Furz-Ding hat heute ein H.264-Decoder. Native-Web-Dev, ja, aber
das ist ja jetzt schon sehr angesagt. Also, ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt riesengroß
mehr wird als 2021. Ja, es wird auf jeden Fall mehr, aber nicht so in diesem rein kein
riesen Sprung. Coole Witz. Homeoffice, eh, tatsächlich. Ja, ich glaube auch, dass 2021
noch mehr Homeoffice am Start sein wird, weil ich denke erstens, dass Corona uns eine Weile
erhalten bleiben wird und zweitens, dadurch, dass man jetzt erkannt hat oder dass immer
mehr Firmen erkannt haben, dass es auch Vorteile haben muss, eh, haben kann und nicht nur Nachteile
haben muss, gehe ich davon aus, dass wird weiterhin ein Thema bleiben und noch eine
wichtige Rolle spielen in 2021. Warum SETGE? Beste. Homeoffice ist das Beste, was die letzten
zehn Jahren IT-mäßig passiert ist. Echt? Wirklich? Stellen die Skype ein? Oder bei
euch auf der Arbeit? PWA glaube ich nicht, hatten wir gerade schon, PWA glaube ich nicht
aus dem einzigen Grund, weil Apple drauf scheißt und Sachen nicht richtig unterstützt. Web
Assembly, wie gesagt, auf jeden Fall. React View, ja, ja, sehe ich ganz genau so. Angular
ist überhaupt nicht mein Fall. Ich bin ja View-Fan, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich
da nennenswert was tun wird. React View Angular ist jetzt schon vorne Mitte bei und das wird
es auch weiterhin sein. Skype for Business wird bei euch abgeschafft, mein Beiler, dass
ihr das noch habt. Den Kram hatten wir auch. Skype for Business gibt auch so eine tolle
Story von der Arbeit, ja. Ich muss aber langsam aufpassen, wenn ich sowas erzähle, weil ich
darf es nicht übertreiben, denn nicht, weil ich irgendwas leake oder so. Ich weiß, ich
erzähle manchmal die, ich erzähle manchmal, ich muss jetzt vielleicht mal vorher sagen,
ich erzähle manchmal die Storys so, als bin ich da schlaust und hab's eh schon immer
vorher gewusst. Das stimmt natürlich nett. Ja. Ich hab bei genauso vielen Sachen keinen
Plan und er liegt auch falsch. Zumindest, nachdem ich das jetzt gesagt hab, ja, geht er. Ehrlich
gesagt, es gibt kaum einen, der wirklich 5-Head ist. Die meisten Leute sind in 99% der Sachen
eigentlich 2-Head. Nein, es muss kein Cobalt und auch kein ABAP auf die Liste, aber in
manchen Bereichen oder in ein paar Bereichen sind manche Leute vielleicht 4-Head, ja. 5-Heads
gibt es nur ganz, als richtige, echte 5-Heads gibt es nur ganz wenige. Hi, es ist T-Monster,
13 Monate. Boah, Massive. Zumindest, um jetzt nochmal kurz die Sache zu Skype for Business
bei uns auf der Arbeit zu erzählen. Ich will mich aber jetzt nicht so sehr um Skype for
Business auslassen, wer das nicht kennt. Muss man vielleicht auch nochmal sagen, Skype for
Business hat mit Skype überhaupt nichts zu tun. Skype for Business ist ein Reskin vom
Office-Communicator, der aussieht wie Skype. Also, sprich, Skype for Business ist weder
Skype noch Office-Communicator, ne, ne, warte mal, nicht Office-Communicator, doch Lynx,
ne. Lynx, Lynx. Davor, davor war das aber Office-Communicator. Davor war das Office-Communicator,
genau. Ja, und das hat mit Skype überhaupt nichts zu tun, die haben das alte einfach
reskinned. So, und wir hatten das auf der Arbeit auch und das waren auch 4 Teams. So,
und dann gab es, wir haben so automatische Jobs laufen im Hintergrund, die ab und zu Dinge
machen, und wenn die abbrechen, haben manche Leute gesagt, ey, das wäre doch cool, wenn
wir dann ne Instant-Message, über den Instant-Messenger Nachricht geschickt bekommen, wenn irgendein
Background-Job abgebrochen ist. So, und da haben unsere Leute, die für intern, für
so Kommunikation und sowas zuständig sind und auch für Atlassian-Systeme und alle möglichen
Sachen, haben gesagt, nein, das ist mit, das ist mit Skype for Business nicht möglich,
das ist nicht machbar mit der Technologie. Dann bin ich auf GitHub gegangen und hab einfach
mal gesucht, Skype for Business API, hab was gefunden, es ist übrigens XML, ist eines
der hässlichsten APIs aller Zeiten. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob ich überhaupt noch Example
finde. Ja, hier. Moment, Moment, Moment. War das gar kein XML? Erzähl ich euch jetzt
mal. Ah, Exzellent. Genau, genau. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. So, so, so, so. So, und, ja, Pratt
Trooper, ich bin froh, dass das weg ist. Hab gesagt, das ist technisch nicht möglich.
Also bin ich auf GitHub gegangen, hab geguckt, wie das funktioniert, und ich hab dann ein
bisschen, ein bisschen gebastelt mit der App hier und bin drauf gekommen, wie das Ganze
Du musst dir erst einen Token holen und sonst was und habe ich einen Curl-Aufruf gemacht.
Mit einem popeligen Curl-Aufruf habe ich dem Typ, also den Leuten, die gesagt haben, das
geht nicht, eine Nachricht über Curl geschickt, dass es doch geht, mit dem Instant-Messenger-Zeug
zustellen.
Leider ist es nie zur Implementierung gekommen, weil die Leute, die das ursprünglich haben
wollten, die wollten es nicht mehr und jetzt haben wir ja Teams am Start.
Die haben einfach keinen Bock, was ich verstehen kann.
Wer macht denn gerne Skyfall Bustas und hat auch noch einen XML-API, alter?
Niemand.
Nein, Patrick, auch wenn du dir die Emotes designt hast, Cobalt muss nicht auf die Liste.
Aber die Emotes sind richtig poggers, alter.
Wir können aber einen Cobalt-Emote machen.
Weiß nicht, wie das aussehen sollte.
Hast du mal per AP in Teams einen Coil gestartet?
Nein, so mutig war ich dann doch nicht.
Wupp, Cobalt.
Ja, ich bin, ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich bin auch kein riesiger Yammel-Fan.
Also, wenn es nach mir geht, könnte man das ruhig alles in JSON machen oder in CSV.
Ne, also man könnte das eigentlich alles in JSON machen.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass jedes JSON valid Yammel ist, auch wenn es komplett unterschiedlich
aussieht?
Das ist auch nicht, was die geritten hat.
Ihr findet es doch eigentlich netplan, Scheiße, finde ich netplan.
Übelst der most useless Crap aller Zeiten.
Kennst du dich mit Asherbots und der Craft-RP aus?
Nö.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab noch kein Asherbot gemacht.
IFTTT ist cool, aber gerade seit diesem Jahr viel uninteressanter geworden, weil sie den
Leuten Abos antreten wollen.
Das läuft zum größten Teil auf so alten oder auch neuen IBM Großrechnern, ja.
Kotlin, ich kann, also es haben jetzt schon viele Leute gesagt, ich, mein Problem ist
damit, ich hab von der Java-Welt keine Ahnung.
Ich mein, ich kann Java lesen, ich könnte auch Java ein bisschen was programmieren,
aber ich hab halt keine Ahnung.
Nein, wir suchen nicht coole Dinge für 2021, wir suchen Dinge, wovon wir ausgehen, dass
die 2021 schwer angesagt sein werden.
Von welcher Klasse stammt hier das Objekt in Java ab?
Na, ich würd mal sagen von der Klasse Object, aber sicher bin ich mir nicht, ich mein es
ist Java-Logik, das heißt, muss nicht unbedingt so sein.
Also in C-Sharp ist es Object, aber in Java könnte es auch Base oder sowas sein oder
Object Factory Single Manager Message oder so.
Was ist eigentlich deine Hauptprogrammiersprache, die Hauptprogrammiersprache in dem Sinn hab
ich nicht, ich versuch eigentlich am ehesten das zu nehmen, was halt am besten passt, aber
am liebsten mag ich C-Sharp und ich muss euch auch, der Chat wieder, lasst sich nicht debaten
vom Chat, ich krieg Anfälle, C++ die schlechteste Programmiersprache, die es überhaupt gibt.
Also am liebsten mag ich C-Sharp und ich muss sagen, mittlerweile, umso mehr ich in JavaScript
mache, umso besser gefällt mir JavaScript, aber ansonsten würde ich sagen, Ruby und C-Sharp
sind meine Lieblingssprachen und mittlerweile ist JavaScript tatsächlich auch ganz okay.
Wenn man das++ weglässt, dann ist C, ja das stimmt, das ist tatsächlich so, C ist
eine super Sprache, die halt, sag mal so Feature-mäßig nicht viel kann, aber halt es überall gibt
und in sich irgendwie auch konsistent ist.
Nein, modernes C++ ist ja fast noch, also okay, du hast recht, modernes C++ ist besser als
altes C++, aber selbst modernes C++ ist immer noch absolute Zumutung.
Ich frag mich ernsthaft, was sich das standardisieren, was die sich da vorher rein knallen, dass
die auf so Ideen kommen, wie beispielsweise die Lambda-Capture-Syntax und sowas, was ist
mit euch los.
Pointer, das ist auch so ein Ding in C++, wo keiner mehr durchblickt, ja.
Auf der einen Seite sagen sie, du darfst keine Raw-Pointer mehr verwenden, auf der anderen
Seite musst du manchmal Raw-Pointer verwenden, ich meine, wenn C++ interop mit C nicht richtig
funktioniert, ja was ist denn dann, ähm, ja, ohne scheiß Iterate, das in C++ ist auch
so ein Thema voll für'n Arsch, ähm, dann, dass die verschiedene Pointer-Konstrukte haben,
die aber schon wieder deprecated sind, ich will jetzt nicht von C++ anfangen, weil wenn
ich von C++ anfange, hör ich gar nicht mehr an, hör ich gar nicht mehr auf und bin die
ganze Zeit nur im Rumflayen.
Hast du Informatik, nee, hab ich nicht, die Sprache ist zu pfeifert, für jeden ist C++
zu pfeifert, selbst für C++-Erfinder und C++-Cremium-Mitglieder ist C++ zu pfeifert.
Ja, das stimmt schon, dass es ein bisschen unintuitiv ist, das ist richtig, aber ich
finde, man gewöhnt sich dran und mittlerweile finde ich JavaScript wirklich gar nicht so
schlecht.
Na feiern würde ich nicht unbedingt sagen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine der zurzeit
angesagtesten Sprachen.
Ja, nee, noch nicht mal, noch nicht mal, ich hab mal Fachinformatik in Systemintegration
gelernt 2007.
Aber ich interessiere mich schon ewig lang fürs Programmieren und ich sag's dir auch
immer wieder, letztendlich muss man auch mal sagen, es kommt hauptsächlich darauf an,
was man auf der Arbeit macht und was man da lernt, der Unterschied ist jetzt nicht so
wahnsinnig.
Du kannst A.E., also Fachinformatik Anwendungsentwicklung gelernt haben und gerne Cloud-Hackermans machen
und du kannst Fachinformatik in Systemintegration gelernt haben und gerne Microcontroller programmieren
oder so.
Das eine hat mit dem anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Eigentlich wollte Max was mit Holz machen, ja, genau, das hat mir damals der Arbeitsamtberater
vorgeschlagen, das weiß ich noch, meine Ausbildung soll ich was mit Holz machen.
Richtig, richtige Dappen, ey, ganz ehrlich, das ist so ein Ding, das ärgert mich bis
heute.
Dieser überhebliche Dapp vom Arbeitsamt, alter, der geht mir so auf den Kick, ich war damals
mit meiner Mutter beim Arbeitsamt, da war ich keine Ahnung, Schule, Realschule, Zeit,
so, was war das, wie alt ist man da, 17, 16 oder so, keine Ahnung, war ich beim Arbeitsamt
und haben wir uns beraten lassen, beraten lassen von so einem Arbeitsamttyp, ja, und
da gibt es so einen Test, was würden die Leute gerne machen und ich habe den halt gewissenhaft
ausgefüllt und ich habe halt überall gesagt, ja, ich würde halt gerne so Computerzeug
machen, so bei allem, bei allem habe ich das dabei geschrieben, da hat er sich danach
übelst drüber lustig gemacht, da waren dann so Fragen drinnen so, möchten Sie gerne
ihr handwerkliches Geschick oder setzen Sie gerne ihr handwerkliches Geschick ein oder
sowas, ja, da habe ich geschrieben, ja, klar, klar, und da hat er mich gefragt, wie ich
das meinen soll, ja, ich baue gerne einen Computer zusammen und bastle gerne ein Hardware
rum und sowas, klar, mach ich gerne, und da hat er sich lustig drüber gemacht, so nach
dem Motto, ja, ja, alles ist hier irgendwie gemünzt auf Computer oder irgendwie sowas
hat der Typ gesagt, so richtig überheblicher Dapp war das beim Arbeitsamt, richtig, Patrick,
exakt genau das, so, und danach hat er mir erzählt, danach hat er mir erzählt, ich sollte
was mit Holz lernen, also Schreiner oder so, ey, ich finde es super, dass es Schreiner
gibt, aber ich kann das nicht und ich habe da keinen Bock drauf, ja, der Typ vom Arbeitsamt
ist ein richtiger, aber richtig, genau so sieht es aus, ja, so, und der wollte mir,
der wollte mir, ja, genau, korrekt, korrekt, und mittlerweile weiß ich auch warum er das
gemacht hat, ganz einfach, weil die einfach viele offenen Stellen hatten beim Arbeitsamt,
was mit Holzarbeit zu tun hat, und der Ziel so einer Beratung beim Arbeitsamt ist es nicht
etwa, so was man denkt, die Leute zu beraten, sondern die Leute dazu zu bekommen, eine Ausbildung
in dem Bereich zu machen, wo viele Firmen gesagt haben, sie suchen Leute, das ist der
eigentliche Grund dahinter, hat er auch nicht.
Der Drexel-Stream, ich hätte einen, ich hätte einen Trämel anzubieten, da könnten wir irgendwo
in irgendeinem Plastikkase mal ein Loch reinschneiden oder so, ach, wir haben ziemlich viele hier,
ich würde mal sagen 90%, kann durchaus sein, ja, da kannst du überhaupt nichts drauf geben,
ja, richtig, ähm, wie hast du programmieren gelernt, weil ich habe erst vor ein paar Monaten
mit meiner Ausbildung als Anwender und Entwickler angefangen muss, sagen, dass die Schulmethode
mal wieder für, na gut, Berufsschule ist ja wirklich, also Berufsschule ist, nee, Lowbrain
ist das, nee, also Berufsschule kannst du wirklich vergessen, das wichtigste, und das
ist übrigens eine Sache, die für alle Bereiche in der IT gilt und wo ich sogar mal behaupte,
die gilt für alle Bereiche überhaupt, das mit Abstand wichtigste ist, dass man sich
für das Themengebiet interessiert und dementsprechend auch einen Zug dazu hat, sich selbst damit
zu beschäftigen.
Also sprich, das beste, was du machen kannst ist, dich selbst damit zu beschäftigen, ja,
überleg dir irgendwelche Sachen, die du gerne programmieren willst, was dich vielleicht
nervt, was du, oder vielleicht wohl dir schon immer gedacht hast, hey, das würde ich gerne
mal ausprobieren, sei es jetzt Desktop-Anwendungen, irgendwelche Server-Geschichten, Webseiten,
was auch immer, such dir ein Gebiet aus, was dich persönlich am meisten interessiert
und fang einfach an, ja, und das funktioniert nur, wenn man sich dafür interessiert, ich
hab das ja schon oft gesagt, dadurch, dass du in einem Gebiet bist, was dich interessiert,
hast du die Chance, quasi in diesem Gebiet was dazuzulernen, und dadurch, dass du was
dazugelernt hast, hast du wieder größere Chancen, dass du in dem Gebiet einen Job findest,
oder halt, dass du einen Job findest, wo du halt hauptsächlich das machen kannst, was
dir Spaß macht.
Und dadurch, dass du das machen kannst, was dir Spaß macht, und wo du dich auch privat
damit beschäftigst, wirst du wieder besser, und die Chancen, dass du einen Job findest,
wo du vielleicht sogar noch mehr Kohle bekommst, und sonst was, in einem Gebiet, wo du, was
dir Bock macht, werden immer höher.
Also das wichtigste ist, dass man sich was aussucht, wo man wirklich Bock drauf hat,
und, dass man halt am Ende auch was kann, ja, es gibt so viele, es gibt so viele Leute,
die ein bisschen Windows-AD klicken können, Millionen, ja, braucht kein Mensch so viele,
oder es gibt, es gibt Millionen Leute, die ein bisschen, die eine Webseite zusammenklicken
können, gibt's auch, es braucht auch kein Mensch so viele.
Ja, wenn man auf gar nix Bock hat, dann ist wahrscheinlich eher die Sache, dass man in
dem Bereich komplett falsch ist, ja, ähm, und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das in
anderen Berufsfeldern nicht so wichtig ist, aber gerade wenn es um IT geht, hier, guckt
euch das mal an, es gibt laufend neuen Scheiß, und 90% davon ist overhypeder Shit, der eigentlich
kein Mensch braucht, der entweder der gleiche Aufguss von letztem Jahr ist, oder aber irgendwas
ist, was managementmäßig voll angesagt ist, aber eigentlich totaler Müll, aber es passiert
laufend was noch, und man muss selbst irgendwie die Übersicht behalten zwischen diesem ganzen
Kram, was ist das eigentlich alles, was da vorne ist Kacke, wie gesagt 90% ist komplett
unsinnig, aber man muss halt so weit durchblicken, dass man erkennt, was sind die 10% sinnvollen
Sachen.
Ja, und wie ich Programmieren gelernt habe, kann ich euch auch nochmal kurz dazu erzählen.
Also ich hatte so ein paar Sachen, das allererste, was ich gemacht hab, bin ich mir jetzt gar
nicht mehr, ich glaube, das allererste, was ich versucht habe, ist damals, als ich MMOs
gespielt habe, also bei mir hat es damit angefangen, dass ich halt was Spezielles machen wollte,
und das ist auch immer das Beste, was man machen kann, wenn man wirklich was im Kopf
hat, was man machen will, und man sucht sich was dazu raus, wie man es am besten umsetzen
kann.
Also ich wollte ein Chat-Auswertungstool basteln, das war eines der ersten Sachen, die ich je
gemacht hab, für einen MMO, was ich gespielt hab, weil der MMO-Anbieter hat sich gedacht,
wir verbieten den Spieler den Klein zu minimieren.
So, und dann wollte ich das so machen, ich wollte Chat-Log anmachen, Chat-Log konnte
der, das geht der Game Klein, ich hab das Chat-Log angemacht, ich wollte anhand der
Sachen, die im Chat geschrieben werden, wollte ich im Hintergrund verschiedene Sachen ausführen.
So ein halber Bot, wenn du so willst, quasi.
So, und das war das erste, was ich gemacht hab, ja, hab ich natürlich voll verkackt
am Anfang, aber klar, ja, und dann so richtig angefangen hab ich, frag mir nicht, 2000,
2002 oder so, als.NET noch relativ neu war, ziemlich frisch als.NET 2.0 Beta oder Gradrelease
war, weiß noch, Generics waren der neueste Shit damals, und da hab ich mich angefangen
für Windows-Desktop-Zeug zu interessieren, und da hab ich damals, hab ich.NET gelernt,
C-Sharp gelernt, und ich hätte damals nicht gedacht, dass das immer noch meine Lieblingssprache
ist, 20 Jahre später, oder 18 Jahre später.
Richtig Boomer, das ist ja kein Geheimnis, ihr wisst doch, dass ich 36 bin, also viele
sind davon immer überrascht, ich weiß, aber so ist es halt.
Wie gesagt, ich glaub, die meisten, nicht alle, wir haben auch manche, die sagen, Alter
Max, ich hör dir gern zu, aber ich hab keine Ahnung, was du davon hier gibst.
Was ist das?
AI-Based Cobalt Transpiler, was?
Was wollen die überhaupt von mir?
Das Sören ist am Start, oh, das ist hippes Start-up, wenn man den Hund auf die Mitarbeiterseite
macht, aber wir haben in den Stellenanzeigen gelernt, man muss fit sein in HTML und CSS-Architektur.
Das sind Sachen, die ihr Bocken mischt überhaupt nicht, also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte, dazwischen
und dazwischen, wüsste ich sofort, was ich mach.
Das muss ja mal auch liegen, Elektrotechnik ist tatsächlich Big Brain, da haben wir den
passenden, da haben wir jetzt auch das passende E-Mode dafür übrigens, woop, boom, cobolcowboys.com,
das wird ja immer schlimmer, Professionals for Legacy Cobalt Systems, ah yes, genau das
richtige für mich, da soll ich mich mal bewerben, ich mein ich hab jetzt ja schon, also zumindest
mal fortgeschrittene Cobalt-Kenntnisse nach dem letzten Stream, muss man sagen.
Ich mein, guck dir mal, ich kann Cobalt besser als 99,999% der Weltbevölkerung, also wenn
das nicht schon fortgeschritten ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Da klicke ich nicht drauf, ey, Alter, achso, Moment, ich hab Deviant Art gelesen und Deviant
Art kanns auch durchaus sein, dass ich jetzt irgendwelche weeb Toss-Bilder krieg, das kenne
ich, das ist aber, ey, bei uns auf der Arbeit ist es tatsächlich so, zu 90% sieht das wirklich
so aus, außer, dass wir eine haben, die hat, das weiß ich, weil die mit mir die Ausbildung
gemacht hat in der gleichen Firma, fast in der gleichen Firma und Abschlussprüfung
hatte, die hat absichtlich gesagt, also die hat Anwendungsentwicklung gelernt, die hat
absichtlich gesagt, sie lernt Cobalt für genau so einen Scheiß, eigentlich richtig
big brain move, richtig next level brain, ja, gibt es nicht irgend so einen YouTube Typ,
der immer im Dinosaurier Schlafanzug rum sitzt, vielleicht ist er auch Cobalt Entwickler,
kenne mich in YouTube Deutschland nicht aus, ich schnapp nur immer Sachen links und rechts
auf, wieso gibt es keinen 7-Head, ja, irgendwann sind die Emoji auch mal begrenzt, aber 6-Head
ist doch schon breit genug, ApoRed hat Beef, ApoRed gibt es noch, hat nicht sein Channel
gelöscht, wollte jetzt krasser Rapper werden, dachte, dachte, den gibt es nicht mehr, endlich
interessiert mich das überhaupt nicht, was YouTube Deutschland abgeht, es ist mir wirklich
mittlerweile voll, früher habe ich mich dann immer noch drüber aufgeregt, aber mittlerweile
ist mir das vollkommen egal, so Leute 22.15 Uhr, ich gehe jetzt ins Bett, sagt dir der
Banana Planner was, klar, den kenne ich noch, das ist da, wo der Friseur eine Montage hochgeladen
hat von dem, der Friseur hat YouTube Comeback gemacht, hier der Friseur, der hat sogar,
der hat sogar ein richtig krasses Streaming Setup am Start, passt mal auf, äh, nein,
warum hat der eigentlich 50, 50 Accounts, alter, der hat jetzt richtig Big Brain Streaming
Setup, guckt euch das mal an, äh, wo ist das Bild, alter Instagram, please, ich logge
mich jetzt nicht ein um mir das Bild anzugucken, der Triple Monitor Setup mit Elgato Keylights
und alles, der hätte das Bild ja auch mal auf Twitter anhängen können, ja, warum hat
er denn das gleiche Keks im Avatar, hat er nicht, er hat einen Pokemon Keks und die Friseur
Frisur, es gibt keinen Keks Avatar Generator, es gibt nur zwei, es gibt, stimmt nicht,
es gibt drei Keks Avatare, der Fabian hat einen, ich habe einen und es gibt noch einen
Mädchen Keks, aber da will ich nicht drüber reden, warum es den gibt, das hat andere Gründe,
der kann keine Bilder anhängen, ja, nein, nein, mit der Sylvana hat das nichts zu tun,
ja, also falls irgendjemand bei Instagram ist und direkt Link posten kann, dann zeige
ich euch das Setup von Fabian, aber der hat jetzt richtig, richtig Big Brain Streaming
Setup, hier konnte er doch auch Bilder anhängen, warum kann er hier gerade Bilder anhängen,
ja, Poros, nice, Dankeschön, Nino Kuni, ist das seine PS3 oder was hat er daneben dran,
ah ne, der ist die Switch, komm mal hier, der hat richtig, richtig Massive Streaming
Setup, der Fabian, der hat jetzt ein professionelleres YouTube und Streaming Setup am Start als
ich, deutlich professioneller, ja, hier guck mal mit Beleuchtung, mit vorne hinne, 3 Triple
Monitor Setup, Kamera in your face, richtig poggers, ja, bei mir sieht das so aus, links
im Monitor, rechts im Monitor, jetzt aktuell gerade ein bisschen dreckiges Schreibtisch
und das wars, stimmt ne Webcam brauch ich nicht, das ist richtig, was hat er denn da
eigentlich für ein komisches Ding am Start, was ist denn das, sieht aus wie ne zu groß
geradene Raspberry Pi Cam, ich weiß, dass es ne Kamera ist, aber was für eine, Tastatur
braucht er dringend, dringend eine RGB, eine mechanische RGB Tastatur, ach das sind, das
sind Lautsprecher, da oben ist die Kamera oder was, da oben ist die Kamera, ach das
sind Lautsprecher, ne oder, Keg Weight, Razer Lautsprecher, warum, warum kauft man sich
denn sowas, Razer Lautsprecher sagen bestimmt richtig eftig, ist er eigentlich on, nope,
den haben wir so auf Twitch, wer will uns denn auf Twitch gerade vor, ich gucke mal
wer nicht hosten kann, wir gucken jetzt mal, heute hosten wir mal jemand, ich roll mal kurz
runter, wer von Deutschen den ich followe ist denn am Start, Knossi, ja klar, weil Knossi
ja unbedingt den Host braucht, also das ist, keiner da, keiner da, keiner da, den Cyrus
könnte man hosten, den, wobei WoW ist jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht so das, was ihr sehen
wollt, ja es ist, es ist mal wieder kein Deutscher, der Lost ist auch nicht on, es ist mal wieder
kein Deutscher da, den man hosten kann, kennst du Stay, sagt man das nicht, so viel, ne,
ok also, man kann doch, man kann, jetzt gucken wir mal, man kann doch jetzt, man kann doch
Twitch irgendwie filtern jetzt, guck mal, ich werde mir, ich werde mir einfach mal selbst
empfohlen, man kann doch Twitch filtern nach German, ist das Montana Black, was hat der
denn mit dem, hä, weh ich nicht, wer ist denn, das ist aber nicht Montana Black, warum
ist der da, die reacten bestimmt irgendwie drauf, ok, Gehr, Mann, so mal mal, wer ist
da, wer trendet da gerade, ich, ich bin oben, perfekt, alter ich kenn die alle nett, ich
kenn keinen, ich kenn niemand, what the fuck, das kann doch nicht sein, kann man komplett
Twitch, den kenn ich, kann man nicht irgendwie komplett Twitch sortieren nach deutschen Streamern,
nicht nur einzelne Kategorien, ich bin zu dumm für Leute, ich kann Twitch nicht, ich
bin zu unfähig für Twitch, Dankeschön für den Sub, it's Willow, ich guck jetzt mal schnell,
ob ich nicht noch Subs übersehen hab, Dashboard, aber Dankeschön, Massive IQ Sub, eh, abonniert,
abonniert, ne, ich glaub ich hab, nix übersehen, alles klar, dann geh ich einfach so auf, bis
dann, macht's gut, wir sehen uns morgen, oder ich hoffe mal morgen, gucken wir mal, see you.